- [Narrator] These nuns
can even break bricks
with their hands
and the purpose behind
this practice is sacred.
(energetic funk music)
(playful music)
The Drukpa Order is a branch of Buddhism
that has been around
for thousands of years
but in 2008, the nunnery
based in Katmandu, Nepal
started to learn Kung Fu
as part of their spiritual practice.
Jigme wanted to be a nun
since she was a little girl.
No other nunnery in Nepal
does Kung Fu training
(nuns yelling in unison)
and Jigme and her
sisters go the extra mile
to master this art form.
They run and climb up stairs
to strengthen their bodies
and they used sticks and fans
to enhance their coordination.
And the purpose of training
these nuns to fight
all comes back to the philosophies
of peace and equality.
The nuns also take these philosophies
and apply them to disadvantaged
communities in Nepal.
In 2015 when a devastating
earthquake hit Katmandu,
the nuns knew this was
their call to action.
The nuns also biked 14,000
miles throughout Nepal
to protest against the human
trafficking of women and girls.